the University of North Carolina is
relocating a toppled Confederate
monument and many students do not like
it hundreds protested at the campus in
Chapel Hill last night in Chapel Hill
last night one group says the decision
to move the statue to a new five million
dollar campus building is creating what
they believe is a safe space the white
supremacy David Berg know is here in
studio with the move that the University
says it has to make David good morning
Gil good morning the silent Sam monument
honors North Carolina's Confederate
soldiers who died during the Civil War
it was pulled down by protesters in
August after more than 100 years on
campus now many students say they wanted
gone for good but the University says
even if they want to they can't legally
do it several hundred students marched
through the UNC Chapel Hill campus
Monday night some scuffling with police
while protesting the school's decision
to relocate the Confederate monument
known as silent Sam since 2015 across
the country more than 100 monuments and
Confederate symbols have been removed
but a recent report finds there are
still more than 700 Confederate
monuments in the US and nearly 100 of
them are in North Carolina I have a
preference to move it off campus but
like everyone here I swore to obey the
law Chapel Hills administrators say as a
public state university it really had no
choice but to keep silent Sam on campus
a 2015 law passed in North Carolina
prohibits state agencies from
permanently removing or even relocating
state owned memorials or statues bill
keys is on the UNC Board of Trustees
he said he supports the university's
plan but he can't ignore the history
behind that monument this monument is a
reminder that black people were owned by
white people as property and that the
institution of slavery was enforced by
unconscionable brutality in the
university's proposal UNC says more than
five mill to five million dollar
building that will house the statue is
also going to house other historical
artifacts now it's a
expected to open in 2022 but the UNC
Board of Governors is going to be next
week to review this proposal IANA you'll
be following that David thank you